[Music]
foreign
I got the audition from Mayans and the
way that happened it's kind of crazy is
I did a
skit comedy thing called dads and Parks
it's on YouTube it's just this Dad
sitting at a park talking [__] right
it's just it's kind of fun it did well
it kind of blew up and AMC called us to
say they want a second series of that
and they're gonna put during their
um before the previews they're going to
put these dads apart so we're going to
talk about subjects that make sense to
AMC so like the Marvel movie was coming
out soon end game so we talked about
Marvel and it was just like this banter
got it and I'm in La filming those and
my buddy Steve Howey from Shameless
that's just a homie he's just like uh we
became friends by chance he came on set
one day during our movie production
production and he was a fan of our
YouTube skits it was just Special
Operations making fun of each other
and uh I text myself hey bro I'm in town
filming this skit comedy thing and I
heard mines is still auditioning I don't
have representation I don't know what to
do but I'm interested you know anyone
who goes I actually know the casting
director and I was like oh he goes let
me email her real quick and he emailed
her and she goes can he actually goes I
don't know let me get your stuff so we
set this real I already had the Reel
together right because I'm like I'm
wanting to do this I knew I did enough
research to know what I needed yeah had
a headshot had a real had a bio fold it
over boom hours later boom sides
do we do
we want to like like what if I get it
what the [__] does that even mean you
know what I mean so then like I'm just
like as [__] bro so I'm like reading
these words I'm like there's no way I'm
saying it right because like the [__]
things are crooked so I have my lady
read it for me I'm like okay then I got
it and then I audioed it to myself and I
recorded and all night I'm like
listening to the lines because Steve's
like one rule be off paper dog yeah be
off book just go in there and do it I'm
like oh okay cool cool and then I dude I
I don't know very much about acting
other than like instinctual like just
[__] being in a dog like just do the
thing you know
and so I shave my [__] head fresh I
make my face look I look like the LA
[__] cholo that everyone expects
right like not even a biker dude like I
just showed up with baggy ass pants
[__] Cortez is on you know what I
mean I had a [__] wife beater on and
a [__] it just I just looked like a
typical cholo I don't know what I was
thinking right I'm just like just look
the part bro you know and I'm already
tatted up right that was tatted like as
a federal agent so I was like well it's
a good choice now like it works for this
you know it hasn't worked since bro but
it works since I can't even get a job as
a federal agent on TV bro but yeah so I
show up this [__] uh and me and
wife kind of like we're enjoying the
experience right and so we walk up there
Wendy O'Brien is like sweetest lady in
the world she's she's the one who gave
me the chance right so she let me in the
room and I did the audition and she
gives this big old hug and a kiss on the
cheek and she gives my wife a big hug
and kissing I'm like like [__] they're
friendly here dude like maybe they
brought your wife into the audition bro
I don't know you not bringing up
I mean she like rolled into the room
with you no she just sat outside waiting
okay okay yeah and we're leaving and it
was like what the [__]
watch me girl yeah I do I don't know my
wife yeah
we have this relationship man when she's
with me all the time anyways so it's
like I didn't know any better right and
so we walk out of there she gives a big
old hug and we're like Okay cool so at
the time we didn't move to Utah yet
we're just about to start getting ready
to Utah so we flew back to El Paso had
like 700 bucks my account bro like like
we're trying to figure this out you know
what I mean like I'm doing speaking of
games to [__] keep to keep the bank
you know and uh get an email saying they
want to do a second read I'm like oh
[__] what does that mean they won a
second edition I called Steve like
where's that he goes dude go yes Kurt
Sutter wants to see you now I'm like
okay [__] this is cool so now I got two
characters I got a serious one and a and
a comedy one
so I remember these lines I flew back a
little serious one like a serious dude
and then a comedy kind of piece like
four Mayans for mines there's two
different characters I'm now auditioning
for got it serious dude and some comedy
dude right got it got it and so um I fly
back to LA and the only dude you could
take is my dad because I don't have a
car there my wife has to take care of
the kids and a vacation's over I was
spring break so vacation's over kids are
there and I'm like all right I'm gonna
go back and try and figure this out
showed up looking like a dumb cholo
again like I don't like so where's your
pops that you're like pops get me right
on this audition like what's he saying
bro he rides with the fire Hogs right LA
City [__] MC right and so he's like
really this is amazing I love Sons of
Anarchy right yeah yeah all of a sudden
I finally got that on Friday yeah now
he's proud doing a play actor put on
[__] makeup being a [__] [__] on
TV American hero and [__] but trust me
we have we have conversations about like
if I have an emotional single with
Vinnie I don't know how you do that
hahaha
yeah
he's to show up and and you know he's
you think they have a part for me
can I try and get the job first you know
what I mean like so funny dude that dude
is always so he sits down I go do the
audition and I do the serious one first
and like Steve said Steve Howe was like
you've been to combat there's none to be
afraid of in here you go in there on
this room just be confident as [__] he
goes shake their hands do your peace
shake their hands get the [__] off okay
all right cool so I have that in mind
um I go and do the serious one boom
knock it out and then I get the comedy
piece they're like okay cool we'll get
the second one I was like okay and I do
the comedy piece and somewhere in that
bro I kind of black out dude it's like
Will Ferrell and [__] old school bro
I'm like shoot and I come back and
everyone's like and I'm like
yeah shake hand shake hand shake hand
get the [__] out of there right yeah so
we're leaving man I'm like if it doesn't
help you I was like I [__] think you
did good we're all laughing like it was
real belly laughs you know what I mean
and he's jumping I was like oh Vinnie
he's on my back Jumping on me like that
short bro he's like five seven like
luckily five seven if that he's jumping
on my back and he's like Evan it's so
cool man what if you get it I'm like I
will see and I'll put my arm and then we
just walk to the car dude story has it
when yo Brian said Kurt Suttle was
watching from the Second Story and
watched it was like he was what he was
watching as my dad was doing that and he
was just like yeah that's he said
something like that that's real that's
real boom got the job [__] yeah bro
before this like I independent bro I I
fill my own [__] with the smallest
budget where like I'm eating my crafty
on a tire of a tractor the first day I
said I'm like [__] where's the real deal
dog wow yeah wow oh wow yeah I love that
and and so
you know I I still got a a bunch more
[__] man I I I guess like take take me
back because I know that there was also
you you know you what you went into like
a pretty severe like mental crisis like
you went to you went through like a
pretty severe like you were in a pretty
low place and and I know like a lot of
this was like
you know I mean from our last
conversation that we had with like just
this this this like just regimen of of
medicine that's like these pills that
you're on and stuff like what you know
like was that before this
it's kind of all happening
it's kind of all
you good yeah I'm good I just I I
thought that might be somebody trying to
come in I don't want Bam Bam to kill him
all right all good let's go no I mean
during all this you know we're starting
to see things are getting harder for me
um
you know there's a Thanksgiving we just
moved to to uh Utah and there's a
Thanksgiving and I'm having these
weird night terrors you know I mean it's
hard to explain man because like you
hear all these exaggerated versions of
what PTSD is and and I don't want to
give any like
truth to anybody it's just it's just
someone's idea what PTSD is and some
some have it all kinds of different ways
but I ended up um I was cooking ham for
Thanksgiving
and um
dude I I woke up early to do the
Thanksgiving dinner because I do
Thanksgiving meal I'm the one who cooks
all of it right so everyone chills out
while I do it's just my thing
and it's already late in the day two
o'clock or so I'm starting to heat up
the ham to get dinner ready and um I
fell asleep on the couch man I was just
[__] exhausted and the Honey Baked
Ham the honey was like or whatever was
spilling over to the side and causing a
fire underneath you know in the in the
oven and I'm asleep man and my wife's
like babes fire and um dog
this is like
when I knew I I I I would have these
outer body experiences from this point
I uh woke up and I don't remember any of
it other than watching myself do it but
I jumped over the couch screaming at the
top of my lungs jumped over the couch
again jumped back over the couch ran
shut it off came back and started just
screaming ah like that and in my heart
there was an incident in Afghanistan
where when I wasn't working
the Ranger stuff I would volunteer at
the at the cache like the casualty
casualty collection points pretty much
in in Afghanistan and when one of these
days a family of seven or eight showed
up and they all got burned really bad um
the dad accidentally put I think it was
gasoline in a kerosene lamp and it blew
up when they sat down and eat dinner
like straight up Afghani family right
um and so for dude a month or so I was
helping them I was cleaning their
injuries I was scrubbing them giving
them we're giving them ketamine we're
keeping them alive and we're we're
removing all the dead skin so it doesn't
get infected and then we're covering it
with silverdin and wrapping them up and
setting them on their way and within a
month like every single one of them died
but said the mom and I'm working on
these kids are like kids of my own age
dude and I smell this and so like that
haunted me for so long that the burn
thing is like still a very sensitive
subject to me that I don't understand
like it's something I I haven't been
able to fix sure and so now take it back
I'm cooking this [__] ham with burnt
skins it's a similar [__] weird
distinct smell
um it's kind of like this very you know
it's kind of bridges that gap for me in
that moment and I thought I burned my
family dog I thought I burned them and
it was like my feelings were so like how
did I let that happen and it's almost
like projecting what that father might
have felt when he made a mistake you
know and and I'm screaming over like ah
my wife's like walking to Me Slowly
she's like baby baby
[__]
what was that yeah you know what I mean
like what the [__] was that and the
worst part about it man
is that my now 15 year old son and uh
was right under me as I'm screaming and
he's screaming at the top of his head
thinking I was gonna [__]
I think he thought he didn't no I lost
control he thought like I was gonna hurt
him or something man and
and terrified the [__] out of him and um
you know I think that actually led to
the Future where he he he he doesn't
live with me anymore he lives with his
birth mom and I think he felt very
scared at that moment of of me and and I
it's a hard thing to be a a man in a
house that doesn't know when you're
going to lose control
and it's not a lose control uh it's just
I don't know I don't know it doesn't
feel good to know that that might happen
again and it has happened
three more times
and um I know now that that triggers
something to do with Burns anytime
there's something to do with Burns I can
tell that I I just I kind of
lose contact and I'm like living out of
my body and I'm screaming and I'm
fearful you know
[Music]
thank you